AMD just announced the all-new ryzen
7040 series whoa
amazing and with the headlines are
flying with everybody saying that this
is the M1 Pro killer now with that said
AMD made headlines like this ship being
30 faster than the M1 Pro while having
up to 30 hours of battery life making it
seem like this is by far a shocking good
amazing chip now when we take a deeper
closer look there are some weird things
for example benchmarks that could be
Cherry Picked I'll get into that and
battery life statements that also don't
make sense and some other comparisons
which didn't go against the M1 Pro now
along with those things I'll also going
to cover the M2 Pro which we know is
going to be coming out very soon and how
this AMD
7940hs will compare with the M2 Pro now
before you jump in I was I see yes it
was an awesome show I met a lot of fans
there which was cool but I actually went
to the AMD Booth checked out a bunch of
their laptops I saw the laptops with
this new chip but unfortunately I was
not allowed to test it out and get those
numbers for myself other than what they
picked to show off on stage so I want to
let you know that we will be testing out
these laptops as soon as they're
available doing real world benchmarks
and comparison so make sure you guys
click that subscribe button below so you
guys don't miss out on those now this
new high-end mobile chip from AMD is the
first one that is using the so-called
four nanometer process from tsmc which
technically is built on five nanometer
but that might be a separate video to
get into they said it has over 25
billion transistors that's close to
double compared to their 6 000 series
and of course going down to four
nanometer that helps with extra
transistors but taking a look at the m
one pro that actually has
33.7 billion transistors the 7940 HS is
an 8 core CPU and compared to the M1 Pro
that is actually a 10 core which we'll
also talk about this is important but we
have a bend a core version as well this
thing can go all the way up to
5.2 gigahertz in its turbo boost mode
which of course it will not stay there
unless you have proper Cooling and low
enough temperatures compared to the M1
pro at 3.5 gigahertz which that actually
clocks down to about 3.2 if you're
running it for a long time across all of
the threads and with that one of the
things AMD really focused on is the
neural engine AI processing this is the
first AMG chip that has a dedicated
neural engine and it can actually
support four streams at one time four AI
streams with up to 12 trillion Opera
operations per second the M1 Pro on the
other hand can only do 11 trillion
operations per second so it is slower
but Apple's M2 Chip actually does
15.8 trillion operations per second and
of course we know that the M2 pros and
Max's are going to come out and those
are going to have improved performance
over the M1 Pros now I'm really glad
that AMD is putting a neural engine what
they're calling ryzen AI into these new
chips so many applications now are using
neural engine stuff for example they
showed off video processing and photo
processing and not only is it useful for
those kind of things and the same thing
that Apple does with their photo and
video but also for applications like
photo editing uh where Lightroom can
find skies in the background also things
like video editing and DaVinci Resolve
and so much more now on stage they not
only compared to Apple's processors but
also intels and it was interesting that
they said their x86 competitor and not
Intel specifically and with that with
Intel they also compared to the 12th gen
not the newly released 13 gen and of
course Intel doesn't have any built into
those ships but to be fair with the
neural engine comparison they were going
against the M2 which technically has
more operations uh per second but AMD
still said that it's 20 percent better
now the M1 and the M1 Pro and Max they
have the same neural engine the M2 is
improved which also means that the M2
Pro might use the same exact neural
engine we don't know if it's going to be
upgraded if it isn't that means AMD is
actually ahead which is a great thing I
love competition to push everybody
forward and apple definitely needs it
now before I get back to the CP
performance comparisons talking about
cherry pick numbers as well as battery
life I want to touch on Graphics because
AMD barely spent any time on this they
did show off that their new chip has 20
better graphics performance than Intel's
12th gen lineup but interestingly on
that chart for the M1 Pro it just said n
a which is really weird because there
are games that run well on all the
systems as well as benchmarks and
different video and rendering that can
use Graphics but it simply was not there
now if we take a closer look they said
20 better than the 1280p now we have
compared a lot of Windows laptops that
compared to the M1 Pro and even just the
M1 and M2 Chip and when we take a look
at RAW graphics performance the Intel
1280p which their chip Beats by 20 has
2.2 teraflops of RAW graphics
performance now just the M1 gets 2.6
teraflops that is right in line line
where their new 7940 HS should come in
in terms of graphics performance and the
M1 came out about what two and a half
years ago and the M2 Chip not the M1 Pro
that has 3.6 teraflops of performance
and the M1 pro has 5.3 teraflops of
performance there compared to roughly
2.6 for their new processor so now we
know why they did not show that off on
screen at the event now I have to be
fair with apple of course Apple Cherry
picks their numbers as well they want to
present things as best as possible and
then the truth isn't always completely
lined up like for example Leon Max where
they said that it could beat out the
best Nvidia chip but they didn't show
off the full wattage of that chip now
AMD said that laptops with the ship will
be launching in March and in 2023
there'll be over 250 laptops that have
this lineup of chips available and we'll
be getting these as soon as possible so
if you guys want real world performance
tests against this 7940 HS make sure you
guys hit that subscribe button below now
going back to the performance with the
CPU which is what they focused on they
said that it's 30 more powerful than the
M1 Pro now initially when I looked at
him like this is amazing for nanometer
it's great and it still is really good
but taking a look closer look there's a
couple things that didn't make sense now
their first number was from cinebench
now the first kind of weird thing is
that they didn't say if they are
comparing to the full M1 Pro chip that
is 10 cores or the bin version that is
an eight core chip they're just showing
the performance gains now since their
chip is 8 core setup I would think if
they want to make the numbers look
bigger they could just use that base
model 14 inch for their numbers but
we're not sure yet and with that once
again they're comparing into Intel 12th
gen not the 13th series and I can find
the numbers for the 13th yet but
comparing a higher end chip that was a
replacement for the 12 700
Intel has about an 18 gain with their
new Chips meaning that even Intel's
latest chips that came out are actually
going to be uh very closer closer to
this new AMD compared to the 8 series
now the second part they showed off was
the BMW blunder render here and on
screen you could see that the 7940hs is
going super quick smoking the M1 Pro and
the i7 chip and they had us wait and
wait until it's done just to make that
point and this is where they get the 30
faster than the M1 Pro using blender now
one weird thing is that in blender even
with Mac not being fully developed for
blender arm and metal the metal
performance is way faster using Graphics
than CPU like we showed off in our
initial videos and that beta just came
out and it's getting even better so I
wonder why they didn't use Graphics
rendering instead of CPU when everybody
would because it's much faster and then
of course we have the wattage that is
required for this chip along with the
battery life now on stage they showed
between 15 to 45 Watts now it makes it
seem that this chip could be clocked
down very low but if we take a closer
look this new high-end chip it's
actually a 35 to 45 watt chip the 15 as
if you're using other slower lower end
chips so in order to get this 30 better
CPU performance you need to have 45
watts of power because they're using all
of it that they can whereas the M1 Pro
non-bend uses 30 watts and the bin
version uses 20 two so even if they are
comparing to the unbin 10 core M1 Pro
that means they need 50 percent more
power in order to achieve 30 more
performance and that is with the M1 Pro
now we know that the M2 Pro is going to
be coming out and there's a good chance
that it won't be three nanometer but
with four nanometer being launched and
Apple's laptops coming out at a similar
time A lot of people are saying that it
makes absolute sense for the Mt Pro to
be ran on a four nanometer enhanced node
as well so that would mean that the M2
Pro that this laptop would actually
compete with not the chip that came out
a year and a half before that the AMD is
comparing to well that's going to be a
much more even playing field and this 14
meter process uses 22 percent less power
than the Apple's M2 Chip that came out
that did see 13 improvement over M1 but
required 33 percent more power so the
playing field will be leveled once the
M2 is out and with that that chip is
also going to perform a lot better as
well so that's going to be very
interesting to compare now as you guys
know Rob performance is only one factor
uh that could be accounted it's easy to
advertise that off but actual
performance in real world tests could be
much different for example with the M2
Chip we compared it to amd's best at
that time and even with the M2 MacBook
Air that is fanless the AMD chip smoked
it when it was plugged in in cinebench
but when it came down to real world
performance in Lightroom which uses the
CPU the famous MacBook Air absolutely
destroyed it and that is because of the
unified memory architecture the ram
being right there and the whole system
running much faster now along with that
we have things like video editing and
prores in regular video editing the the
M2 air smoked it already even though it
has much weaker CPU and Graphics but
with prores it was an absolute Slaughter
having those dedicated encoders built
into the M2 which of course the M1 Pro
and M2 Pro chips will also have and
lastly we have to talk about the 30
hours of battery life which sounds
groundbreaking and shocking paired to
four nanometers and people are already
getting really hyped up for this but the
reality is these numbers are often very
skewed like we've seen many times over
with Windows laptops saying 20 hours 28
hours but in reality it's half of what
Apple silicon gets now of course we are
fans but we show these off and test them
on screen running tests in real world
performance and usage now here we have a
commenter saying 30 hours bad enough
that is insane but then somebody else
commenting that previously they also had
high claims but the brightness to
laptops were cut down so much it wasn't
even usable in and the whole test was
not compliant now of course four
nanometer or the version of that is 22
more power efficient but that does not
mean the laptops will have triple the
battery life so I'm pretty sure those
claims are on the 15 watt models with
the brightness shut down very low and
very easy tests and then having windows
and battery saver mode where it's kind
of unusable and it slows down so much
like we've seen in the past whereas with
the M2 Chip the efficiency cores are so
good that even when I made my video on
low power mode the wattage went down to
one to two Watts but it still
outperformed many Windows laptops and it
was completely usable so I think that
number is just very exaggerated I hope
it is near that good but we will find
out in our upcoming Hands-On real world
comparisons how that battery life
actually does maybe we'll even do a
dedicated video on that you guys let us
know if you want to watch it now while
you're waiting if you want to to pick up
an empty MacBook Air which we absolutely
love or a 14 inch with the M1 Pro check
out the YouTube shopping feature you
guys can go and check it out there and
make sure you guys are subscribed above
to see those Hands-On comparisons it's
been Max check out one of those videos
over there and we'll see you in the next
one
[Music]